[Music]
in nice try
buddy news nice try buddy nice dad
brother
submitted by fight me juan on one one
a man scam went wrong so he faked his
own kidnapping to get out of it
that's funny that's good
i love shitty scam artists it's the
funniest thing on earth
that's hilarious it was like when you're
a little kid i was just talking about
this on twitter
this guy was saying um he was watching
his cousin and his cousin didn't finish
his book report so he just didn't go to
school that day
and that was the answer like you got
more time and i remember
we had that as an option like i just
don't go to the place where somebody's
expecting something from me
yeah and that's it like now you got
bills they don't care if you're sick
it's the first yeah i don't care but my
mom don't fam
yeah it's the first i need my money you
gotta go do it
yeah so this man uh so this takes place
in upstate new york
he was playing some something called
super bowl squares
which is a gambling game have you ever
heard of it yeah squares yeah the uh
people do it at um
during the super bowl so how do you play
because i don't know so if it's like you
have like a
like a grid and then there are points on
it and then you
you predict where you think the score is
it's almost kind of it's like like bingo
and gambling but for a football game
yeah but
you do multiple bets per game so it's
not just you don't just bet one score
you bet
multiple scores to see if you get the
closest to the actual final scratch
that sounds pretty fun i feel like i
played that back when i worked at a
hospital but a different version of that
if the patient's going to live or not
for the surgery
no i meant like with my co-workers
that's what i mean i thought everyone
was betting like okay
the heart transplant guys probably not
gonna make it you know when it's like oh
midnight or 11 30. oh god i put 50 bucks
a guess
i think he's gonna make it and it's like
no no no no it's like did you see his
chart it's like he's not gonna be yeah
yeah yeah
all right we both know he's gonna die
but what time though it's like no fair
you can't look at his chart first
[Laughter]
that's funny hey you had insider
information um
okay yeah so this man who's playing that
his name is robert he's 60 years old
he was found in the back seat of a blue
pickup truck
and he was bound with duct tape and then
a rope was tied around his neck
and attached to the headrest apparently
he said that he was robbed at gunpoint
and these robbers they took 16 000
in cash that he had won in the game
and then so for two days he was driven
around
western new york against his will but
then like they left him there and so
that's
how he was found so the cops once they
they were like collecting dna from the
truck like they were like really going
in trying to figure out what happened
here
but then the more they questioned this
dude there was like a lot of holes in
his story
and so finally he ended up after 30
something minutes that's 10 minutes
of telling his story he admitted that he
lied about the whole thing
i give up i give up after 35 minutes
yeah
i thought you're going to see 35 days he
rolled on himself
he knocked himself on himself after 35
minutes
yeah he had three days to work on his
story that's as [ __ ] fast as i'm
telling you [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] it okay i'll tell you
damn you cracked me yeah so like what's
his name took like
at least three weeks or whatever and he
still hasn't admitted it oh jesse small
and jesse smaller
he's i gotta i'm going to the grave with
this exactly my truth
exactly i respect a man who stick to his
principles this guy
30 minutes of your own lie unbelievable
the streets is not respecting that
apparently what he did is
so this super bowl squares game had a 50
000 payout
but he rigged it by making up names on
some of the squares
and so but he didn't end up winning so
he found
out that he had to pay 50 000 to the
winner
oh lord so that's when the whole
kidnapping thing
and robbery plot happened so why didn't
he ask for fifty thousand instead of
fifteen like you should have been like
they robbed me for fifty thousand that's
that's a lot
how do you mistakenly get on the hook
for fifty grand right
that's not like a little bit of money i
feel like he you would know that that
much money's on the table before you
make a bet like he's a gamble-a-holic
i've only seen like
celebrities gamble that kind of money so
what was kidnapping supposed to do
how is that gonna get him out of the out
of the thing so he was hoping that he
absolutely did
that guy's picture i mean so he was
doing all this so then he could tell the
winner like
look i was kidnapped and i was robbed
but that's what i'm saying even the
amounts don't make sense
he should have been like they've robbed
me of like 70 000 or something so i
can't pay you back because that was the
money isn't it but he said sixteen
thousand
so where's the other money i spent it
all
sky is all sorts of [ __ ] up looks like
he's
[ __ ] made every wrong decision in
life he does
you know time he's had a chance he made
the wrong edge of the bar drinking by
himself
in a dark ass like old bar he's the guy
who he's the guy who's bummed because
his meth lab didn't work out
yeah and he's like man i tried to start
this meth business this can't get off
the ground he can't even get any
criminal activity off the ground because
he's just been sucking at life
so funny you can't even go to jail right
yeah so the cop said like
this dude has a goatee like it doesn't
look like he's been sitting in a car for
three days
because he they said it's nicely trimmed
that was like a clean shave
the kidnappers were nice and they gave
him a [ __ ] grooming shave
his breath is all fresh and minty
exactly
he's been brushing it using this he
didn't poop or [ __ ] in there at all it
takes a woman
investigating you that's probably it was
probably female officers
yeah women are the best forensic
investigators
absolutely don't smell no pee in here
jesse smallway is like you didn't
[ __ ] hire your friends
right were you an idiot
like you gotta hire your friends man
like that was someone in the car with
you
at least the latest on that story he he
got grand juried
yeah and then he just hasn't been on
instagram yeah what
what is grand jury's name so the the um
the legal the cook county judge or court
system basically gathers a group of uh
people and decide are we gonna bring
charges on him or not and they haven't i
think the police have
um charged him with uh falsifying police
records so i think he's he's waiting for
his trial to be
said this is backfired in the the worst
possible i know the worst episode of
empire ever
he just didn't put any [ __ ] probably
the best and probably the last
for him anyway oh yeah yeah that's crazy
i'm up for the last two episodes um
and it was over a pay dispute see it's
always money yeah it's always money it
always goes back to money
fake kidnapping is always mine it's
always damn
not me it's probably for attention prove
to me that you love me
i want to see how far you'll go i wonder
how long it takes for me to snitch on
myself
that dude lasts 35 minutes i mean he
only had himself to blame
he only had to be loyal to himself and
he couldn't even do it that's what i'm
saying we love playing mafia and [ __ ]
like i would [ __ ]
really work myself to stay in it yeah
that's like the ultimate mafia though
because these fbi or
police uh what do you call it
interrogators they do this
for a job they're dealing with liars on
a day
i could beat them we'll see we'll see
i already called your tail so maybe i
know exactly well now that i know my
tell
and mafia thanks to you oh you guys
talking about the game up here yeah
oh man my family just started we played
the werewolf version
oh okay that's funny ultimate one yeah
my kids are all they're the best liars
ever are they really
they we had a whole game party one time
they blew your mind you're like
they they they're perfect little liars
they tricked me and i was like you're my
son
then they got my son got me killed i was
like there's 20 people playing why are
you going after me
you're that you're that emotional dad
who's like you're my son you're killing
me in this game
but when it's my turn i got him killed
it's all competitive
i thought i had low i thought i had dad
son loyalty great dad yeah
but when it's my turn to kill him
you know what you know what we are we're
petty we're very petty people very
i have to get my revenge i have to i
must gotta do it i didn't talk to myself
for the rest of the night he had me
killed he tricked me
dinner right no dinner christmas what's
that where's your homeless witnesses
exactly don't celebrate it no more you
turn on me
me i brought you into this world i can
ground you son
[Laughter]
i agree with you i love it nobody yeah
so this dude robert he
got charged with a felony
of scheme to defraud and and a
misdemeanor account on falsely reporting
an
incident that's the same they charge
jesse small that was yep falsely
reported but dude only 30 minutes he
broke
you gotta give him some leniency for
that right i think that's why the cops
you know when they bring you into the
room where they're gonna talk to you
it takes time you know like they don't
come in immediately i think they let you
sit there for like an hour or two just
in your life someone that's like that
that can't
like [ __ ] and they let all the anxiety
build up he's probably like knocking on
the window
oh my god i know this is a one-way
mirror but i'll tell the truth i [ __ ]
did it
and they're just pouring coffee like oh
damn everything
we just arrested 16 suspects and he's
like oh [ __ ]
i [ __ ] up yeah we actually had no
evidence on you but
he [ __ ] interrogated himself where
were you
i don't know you're lying i am yeah
that's probably what happened he did a
good cop back cop with himself
poor guy yeah i know i'm like the worst
liar that's why i hate
playing those games you are not a bad
liar anymore you can't say that anymore
well i'm trying to get we've seen you do
pretty good oh from that last one yeah
dude that was so funny
what's cool about those games you're
allowed to lie yes
i know but like it's rewarding i just
i hate like i just i can't i hate it
even nikki told me that you were
wrecking in salem yesterday you got to
use that to your benefit then
if people your friends know that about
you you got to use that to throw them
off yourself she did she threw us off in
the last couple games she was killing it
last couple
she tricked me i've been trying and i
never get tricked she's a viper now dude
that's true created a monster she likes
about everything a lot of the articles
right now
she's [ __ ] with them she made these
fake websites up
i think games like that are so fun
because you could do whatever you want
and it doesn't hurt anybody
yeah yeah it's kind of like war you know
like you could kill whoever you want
and you don't get in trouble for it
that's true
i'd rather just not get involved i'm
like don't my my guilty conscience
why don't you want to play that's why
war crimes are [ __ ] i'm like what
you commit a crime during war like what
it's an anatomy no because yeah that's
the same that's the same thing as like
like time out time out that's that's not
right you can't use gas you can't use
chemical gas
exactly so that is really where you
think about it like we're killing each
other man but come on what you guys are
you're taking all this money it's got at
least we have to go back chemical gas
earlier and it's like yeah but i didn't
use gas that's respectable regulations
on ammunition on the type of rifles they
can use
all this [ __ ] and i'm like you guys are
murdering each other and you're setting
up rules
that's kind of funny we're having a
gentleman's wall i love that
it's a gentleman's wallet if they want
to do that they should have like a
referee in the middle of it
that's the wrong round that bullet is
for vehicles
not for people no legs don't shoot for
the legs yeah
aim for vital organs only that's like
what the un is or whatever they're
probably like they are the game
committee of war they're like alright so
let's let's do this
all right you know let's let's not do
the gas anymore guys in the big bombs
let's not do that
that is so much but it's so weird that
somebody really was like you gotta put
some stipulations on i know
it's like we've taken this war [ __ ] a
little too far i know ridiculous guys
you can't be wearing colors that
disguise you right yeah you got to be a
neon yellow so we can see you what's
going on
hey hey hey no that is hunting they're
like i mean you can kill the deer but i
mean put an orange vest over it make it
at least
competitive i always hear people on the
news and
they're always talking about like uh you
know the taliban or whatever and it's
like
these people they don't wear uniforms or
anything i'm like
yeah it's actually pretty smart they're
actually pretty [ __ ] intelligent
because they're not playing fair
they're also at home you're in their
neighborhood right yeah like
i live there's no army we don't have
army
there's no uniform they're like goat
farmers and [ __ ] like what do you expect
they don't got money for a nice
camouflage suit dude taliban should come
out and be like these are the official
hats of the taliban
we're we're releasing official hats and
then they never wear them
because we're all so stupid we're like
okay that's gonna be the uniform got it
yeah and then they don't wear them we're
gonna absolutely fall for that we would
fall for it
like like where's your honor we have all
the money all the [ __ ] equipment all
the technology you guys are killing us
with planes
yeah from new mexico you're talking
about honor
yeah at least that guy's wearing a
uniform inside of that hunt yeah and
they have [ __ ] muskets and [ __ ] and
you're like come on man where's your
honor
it's like that's almost like killing
somebody with a bow and arrow
what the [ __ ] laser you know
[Music]
you